our next guest has already been drafted
in the first round by Major League
Baseball's Oakland A's will likely be a
first-round pick in the NFL as well but
several sports that have not drafted to
him at all
or no interest from the NBA the NHL is
barely scouted him and as far as we know
no soccer team has reached out yet with
a contract despite those deficiencies he
should pick a sport real soon so we can
all get on with our lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you wanna go sorry - Gatorade
again put it right there I've been on
the show before look at you
now you're now your professional yeah
professional salesman how's that NFL
football feel like I'm not trying to
bait you to make a decision I just wanna
know how that felt
it's different than a college a little
bit yeah all right a lot more well you
can do that your rookie year
waiter we're not gonna get along here if
I do this I I want to make sure okay you
know what to make a decision are you
having fun with this at all in a lot of
usually I couldn't tell oh no don't
worry I've ever loved okay well let me
try this again hey what did you think of
that NFL football where's nothing
where's the Heisman Trophy sleep you do
not yeah yep well where is it like right
here okay but is this an Oklahoma or
parents house yeah so you have like your
phone you may have an alarm clock do
people come over and want to see the
Heisman no wait
no if I live next to you there's one
there's one at the school I don't care
about that one well that's the one like
it Christmas okay yeah I should be able
to say hey where is it yeah yeah pick it
up get a picture with it no you know
it's good
who did you meet along the way when you
were you know the whole Heisman Trophy
ceremony thing was there anybody that
you met at the ceremony where you went
oh boy that's such-and-such who was your
idol growing up my idol hmm what's with
sport Oh mm how about bait well what's
your favorite sport
[Laughter]
I'll say this I like a lot of players
okay yeah who's your baseball idol I was
the you know I was in yeah sorry about
that
yeah I know yeah I don't are you still a
Mets fan no are you know clean A's fan
of course okay I just wanted to make
sure as I thought maybe Rickey Henderson
would have been some do you even
remember no I was waiting Lee huh your
dad would know yeah of course yeah Rick
Ricky was pretty good yeah like really
good he probably could have played
running back he looks he looks like he
was did you watch the Deion Sanders
34:30 about him playing two sports what
time do the air last nine o'clock no I
was busy well what do you mean busy just
sports center
you know if festivities stuff like that
oh you okay so you were doing media tour
yes so you didn't get to watch it no I
did not Oh was he good yeah because I
remember when it happened that it was
pretty amazing
okay went but he took a lot of criticism
I don't know why well they just thought
that maybe it was a publicity ploy and
then he was being selfish like he wasn't
committing to one team and then the
other team I don't get that but also he
was a cornerback
yeah so it's different and that's why
when people say well you know Russell
Wilson was in yesterday and he said you
know I love baseball
hmm but if I dedicate too much time to
baseball than people criticize me like
hey why aren't you studying your
PlayBook
because he's the quarterback so that's
the hard part you know for you because
you could probably play both sports
Oakland Raiders draft you let's say just
hypothetical my herd would rust that
over the phone yeah and that he would
you know he's with the Yankee so he'd
have to play for like the Johnsons yes
you'll do it if the Raiders drafted you
yes would that change anything about
trying to play both in my head I would
love that I already said I would love to
play both I think you know
it's just up to uh that be able to the
other Raiders and the A's do well who do
you think would have a bigger problem
other Raiders really yeah I think Jon
Gruden likes you by the way I appreciate
that
yeah have you talked have you talked to
Jon Gruden okay Paul bring out Jon
Gruden what would you do if he came out
right that's it that's it who else have
you met at the Super Bowl
Oh a lot of people but everywhere I go
it's just like wow you know I'm pretty
done so did you get autographs I didn't
my pictures are like kind of the thing I
guess nowadays so okay yeah doing that
did you exchange jerseys with anybody
this year no no no soccer players do
that you know I'd love the place doctor
too do you think you could play
professionally yeah whoa whoa would give
me like you give me a couple home ones
okay like I gave you three months to
play work on the four I can get an MLS
team into Oakland for sure and then I
got the Oakland Raiders and then I got
the Oakland A's and then I got there's
one in San Jose Paulie I can make this
work I don't know what you got going no
no I got I got a lot of stuff going on
in my head here yeah you could be a
three-sport athlete Gatorade will love
this right yeah all right see what I can
do here I guess uh are you going to the
combine Oh dad is he going to the
combine dad had no comment there pro day
I mean that's after this yeah you're
gonna do a pro day yeah
yeah I guess you would say yeah it's
okay you can have a pro day right
instead I would imply that I was going
to play football uh okay
so you're gonna have a pro day lens
minor when do you report for the Oakland
A's oh you knew that okay so you're
you're ready to go to do that wait are
you going to spring training wait you
don't know dad is he going to spring
training another no comment here you
know these microphones are on right now
I just I just said all right you want to
talk about Gatorade oh okay I drink it a
little too much yeah yeah yeah I'm
Orange yeah I used to be old school like
like the lemon line I'm not a gator fan
Oklahoma sooner fan though right no
although I like Lincoln Riley
I like Baker Mayfield yeah I grew up
loving Oklahoma back long time ago yeah
I mean they were they were bad yeah yeah
did you ever meet Brian Bosworth yeah
he's always wrong oh yes yeah yeah he
was crazy
he was a big big big-time star yeah back
then everybody 44 yeah they had that
jersey the bandana where would you have
gone if he didn't go to Oklahoma after
like yeah honestly uh Oklahoma was the
best situation at the time yeah I'm
supposed to have a year and then leave
but anywhere else and now Hertz comes to
town so what advice would you give Jalen
Hertz Oh obviously it's a new situation
I mean he's been in he's been in tons of
you know hectic
you know hectic games big-time games so
but now he gets playing a fun system
and I think for him it's just uh I think
yeah grasp it's not he's a freshman he
understands no offenses you're probably
a little bit different than Alabamans
but no for him I think it's just making
putting it into his own thing just
playing his own game how tough is it
that you're doing this with Gatorade but
you know every place you go is gonna ask
you the same questions I'm getting
pretty good at answering you know these
questions no you're not answering boys
exactly you're shaking me off here yeah
I feel like I'm trying to tackle you you
know what how long was it before I
brought up the following I didn't ask
about his height 11 minutes in you
didn't bring it so that's got to be a
record right I was told you're gonna be
pretty harsh so harsh
yes no I'm just straight I'm just honest
I like coming right at you like that
yeah that's it no so your official
height and weight I don't know the
official about all wake up and just have
you been measured before the last I
recall my freshman you know okay have
you grown since then Loki I think so
little little bit all right so you're
you're under six feet for sure you look
about sighs you know Russell Wilson was
in here you know and I'm in your corner
like when I hear these Scouts say well
you got to be a certain height and all
that stuff I just want to know if you
know football love football so I didn't
mean Oklahoma's Lyman are as big as the
NFL life doesn't make sense to me
you know I don't get the whole nobody
yeah you seem to do okay yeah breeze did
okay Baker Mayfield still do yeah II
still don't okay
who's the quarterback you wanted me I
haven't no everybody compares the soil
and I haven't got to me trust which is
crazy good man uh yeah no good dude I
was everything I've heard you know
watched uh seems like a great guy but if
you could sit down and pick somebody's
brain right now
what quarterback
it had to be him but I mean like you got
Brady and Rogers all guys but I think
Russ mm-hmm could you beat me in a
40-yard dash if you if I got a 20-yard
headstart
yeah you could could you be you an
athlete
hell yes look at me I was a three-sport
athlete in high school high school yeah
wait well I mean I only play two sports
nice yeah well hello would you play time
to record no did you play I played
freshman quarterback first freshman
quarterback snowsport I started okay
yeah I started basketball in baseball
see I had to get best shortstop
shortstop okay yeah you say you the best
part I could bring I had yeah I don't
know I could bring it yeah I got my
highlight reel up on YouTube yeah he is
Kyler Murray who knows what he's gonna
do the rest of his life consumers can
visit Gatorade calm use the promo code
Gatorade SB for 20% off their perches
through February 17th and I wish you I
wish you a lot of luck here they've got
some big decisions and hopefully your
parents can help you make that decision
it's the right one for you look forward
you seen your plan good luck you know
with the Raiders you said four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]